blake lively's cheerleading throwback is  everything check out the 29 year old and  the vintage shot that she shared on  Thursday that's actually one of my  favorite looks she's literally sitting  on the ground in her black and blue  burbank high school uniform but her arms  are raised in a high V and one of her  pals is half sitting on her shoulders  Blake joked about her laziness writing  quote I've always been impressively  athletic I'm like close I like you know  I like mixing things that are unexpected  Blake's high school shot comes the same  day her hubby Ryan Reynolds may have  spilled the beans on the sex of their  second baby who they welcomed last month  guilty as charged Ryan tweeted quote the  mobile above my daughter's crib is just  a whole bunch of new bearings so she  remembers how lucky she is but does that  mean baby number two is also a girl well  neither Blake or Ryan have commented on  the Twitter speculation I've always been  a little cheeky